[Musique]
bonjour béatrice b les membres du bureau
politique des socialistes de martini
conseillère fédérale à la fsm 48 heures
après la confirmation de la débâcle de
votre parti le score le plus faible en
50 ans à peine plus de 6% lors du
premier tour de la présidentielle
quand on est militante comme vous que se
dit on on a encore envie d'aller au
combat
oui on sait c'est d'ailleurs toute la
force du militantisme c'est de mener des
batailles avec l'espoir de les gagner
tout en étant formé à les perdre
et comme manoeuvre débutants comité
national à la rue de solférino siège
parisien du ps
que voulez vous on attendre vous une
unité une vraie unité c'est possible ça
je pense que le parti socialiste s'est
remis de bien des étapes de son histoire
est celle qui nous restent en mémoire
c'est le congrès de rennes on a on a
réussi à y survivre je crois qu'on
pourra survivre également à ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui
mais willy a profondément
une tristesse dans ce dans les chiffres
aujourd'hui du candidat ps en tout cas
une tristesse ressentie par par les
militants mais aussi une envie de
repartir à la bataille des idées
repartir vers quoi il faut être une
gauche de combat il gauche critique ou
bien jouer la carte de la gauche de
gouvernement faisons maximum les yeux
doux emmanuel macron non il faut jouer
la carte de la gauche unie le premier
secrétaire l'a dit hier d'ailleurs dans
une dans une allocution qui est des qui
est disponible sur internet
jean christophe cambadélis a répété et
que la gauche avait été particulièrement
le parti socialiste avait été désunie
je crois qu'il faut retenir entre une
gauche sociale libérale une gauche
francs 2 ce sont les grands noms ce sont
les courants du ps pour autant je crois
qu'il va falloir qu'on apprenne
peut-être davantage à laver notre linge
sale en famille et à ressortir de ces
étapes difficiles et compliquées plus
forts et plus unis
vous avez certainement entendu manuel
valls il est requis qui avait refusé de
soutenir le champion des primaires de la
belle alliance populaire leurs sept
premiers ministres qui étaient sur
france inter il a dit que le ps était
dans une phase de décomposition de
démolition de déconstruction il a dit
aussi qu'il est moi que ce parti que son
parti soit dans une phase de
reconstruction
venant de lui ça fait quoi comme ico
chez vous ça interpelle
ça interpelle parce que
le manque d'unité vient aussi de ce que
le candidat
nous avions quand même que deux
candidats qui se présentent à la belle
alliance de candidats socialistes il y
avait aussi d'autres parties qui ont
signé une charte qui ont signé un
engagement et en l'occurrence
le l'ancien premier ministre valls n'a
pas respecté ses engagements
parce qu'il aurait dû se taire tout
simplement vous savez vous avez toujours
la possibilité de soutenir sans faire
campagne
ouais des routes nationales et ici en
martinique le ps à ses soucis de
visibilité peu d'élus vous ne posez pas
franchement sur la carte politique
martiniquaise on a l'impression que les
autres formations ont eu du mal à vous
voir en tant que parti présidentiel oui
probablement je crois que la campagne
aussi a été très compliqué elle a été
avant la campagne
la visibilité de la fsm luiz
probablement je pense qu'on a perdu
c'est vrai en dynamisme et en visibilité
on va comme une commande aujourd'hui
l'histoire et le scrutin de dimanche à
samedi et dimanche je crois qu'on a
aussi un besoin chez nous de ce
renouvellement et comment y faire
comment faire on va les convaincre
lorsque vous avez vous quand même député
européen louis joseph manscour il ya le
maire de trinité fred duval qui est en
congé du parti tout comme patricia tel
qui siègent à l'assemblée de martinique
puis c'est tout il va falloir aller
rechercher va falloir aller être
convaincre à nouveau
il va falloir gonfler nos rangs c'est
quoi le mode d'emploi
le mode d'emploi s'est parlé aller au
delà des eaux de vendée vous pensez
qu'on m'avait les entendre et pour qu'on
n'aurait pas envie parce qu'il ya eu
cinq ans il a eu cinq ans de mandats
présidentiels et françois hollande le
temps que s'est pas arrêtée le temps ne
s'est pas arrêté je crois que la
martinique est faite d'histoires et le
monde et fait d'histoire le temps se
passer il faut qu'on le mette au
bénéfice en effet de la transmission
guider socialiste humaniste écologique
écologistes pardon et je pense que nous
avons toute notre place encore dans le
débat politique dans le débat d'idées
le parti socialiste est singulier
singulariser de nombreuses années encore
aujourd'hui par des idées il s'agit
d'être crédible d'études voit
suffisamment forte pour dire là tout de
suite c'est la prochaine échéance de le
deuxième tour de la présidentielle il
s'agit d'être fort pour dire non à
marine le pen en votant emmanuel macron
oui c'est alors on va reprocher ce terme
c'est vrai mais c'est c'est faire
aujourd'hui barrages
et pour nous socialistes sans condition
voilà sans conditions ça a toujours été
le mot d'ordre nous n'avons jamais
bégayer lorsque nous nous sommes
retrouvés dans une situation telle que
celle que nous vivons aujourd'hui en
2002 déjà appel le scrutin était et est
il sorti que le parti socialiste
appelaient massivement à voter pour
chirac
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose nous
appelons à voter macron pour barrer
marine le pen tout en ayant conscience
que ce n'était pas notre candidat oui
mais en même temps vous appelez à barrer
la route à un candidat à une candidate
un parti qui a réussi à ceux des dé
diaboliser son image auprès de beaucoup
d'électeurs
écoutez vous savez on a on a beaucoup
d'expressions en martinique pour dire ça
mais il suffit pas d'être de revêtir le
bel habit pour être une personne bien je
crois qu'il faut se méfier aujourd'hui
des du fn il faut il fallait s'en méfier
déjà mais il faut s'en méfier
aujourd'hui encore davantage la chance
que nous avons pour ce qui est des idées
c'est que nous avons encore les moyens
de sur ce qui nous écartent des manuels
macron de le combattre notamment par les
armes législatives par le combat social
par la lutte aussi qui peut être mené
par par les concitoyens
ça risque d'être plus compliqué avec le
fn dans les premiers rangs du fn vous
voyez des gens en beaux habits et puis
dans les derniers rangs vous y voyez les
fascistes qui font des saluts nazis qui
porte la croix gammée
donc soyons méfiant ce n'est pas un ce
n'est pas une mince affaire et la
distance qui sépare aujourd'hui dans les
sondages enfin pas dans les sondages
dans les chiffres par dont marine le pen
de emmanuel macron n'est pas une
distance si confortable est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose à mes gosses y est avec
emmanuel macron pour le parti socialiste
et plus singulièrement pour la
martinique
pour l'heure nous n'avons pas c'est une
stratégie qui va se décider dans les
mois prochains
en tout cas l'échéance est vrai
législatives est très proche
pour l'heure c'est pas la préoccupation
n'est pas celle là la préoccupation est
réellement ce deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
faire barrage au front national
définitivement radicalement avec force
et fracas montrer aussi au monde que
nous savons faire la différence est que
la france va respecter son image d'
humaniste ce ca france en tout cas de
son histoire des lumières je crois que
pour l'heure le ps ne s'est pas posé
cette question ne se la pose jamais
lorsque l'ennemi est aussi fort que le
fn pour la martinique encore une fois
comme tout juste avant là le premier
tour de la présidentielle écrit ce
mouvement sociétal à ce mouvement social
un en guyane
vous savez ce que la guyane a obtenu à
quelques heures avant le premier tour de
la présidentielle ce que ça pourrait
inspirer les martiniquais ce que vous
pensez que vous en tant que socialiste
vous pourriez aller dire emmanuel macron
dans le cas où il serait élu
la guyane obtenu cela mais les
martiniquais aussi ont besoin de plus de
moyens pour le développement économique
naturellement naturellement on a quand
même des faisceaux ou en tout cas des
statistiques qui nous montre que la
martinique n'est pas sur certains points
si éloignées que ça des conditions en
tout cas où des de la guyane
aujourd'hui alors c'est un des points
que j'ai relevé mais c'est vrai que je
les ai déjà dit emmanuel macron a dans
son programme la diminution depuis de 40
millions 40 milliards pardon de dotation
générale de fonctionnement des
collectivités c'est ce qui permet à nos
territoires de se développer de relancer
la commande publique de faire du service
public également
il va falloir que nous soyons très
vigilants sur ces dispositions car nos
collectivités
claude erreur qu'il a été élu sur un
programme et mais c'est pour ça que nous
devons être vigilants
voilà il nous devons du coup être très
vigilant aussi sur les législatives et
faire en sorte que les élus que nous
mettons en place pour représenter
notamment la martinique soit en prise
avec des valeurs sociales avec aussi la
préservation des moyens des
collectivités
naturellement et aussi avec les soucis
écologique parce que je pense qu'on en a
pas assez parlé mais nous mettrons
l'accent en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne je serai très vigilante à ce
que la partie écologique des programmes
soient aussi respecter on va pas parler
du chlordécone des particules fines
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que tout
tous ces socialistes qui ont rallié
emmanuel macron au dernier moment
est-ce que cela pourront peser pour
avoir une certaine influence sur lui
nous l'espérons c'est ce que nous
espérons nous espérons que garderont ce
sens je ne sais pas si ça a été fait en
ce sens mais quoi qu'il en soit les
socialistes en question reste socialiste
est il le réaffirme nous tâcherons de
les ramener à la maison déjà et nous
verrons comment cette affection qu'ils
ont eue pour le candidat macron pourra
aussi venir influencer la politique
monsieur m'a chrome et remplacer si il
était nu dernière question il nous reste
à peine 30 secondes
tout se décidera pour les socialistes au
soir du deuxième tour des législatives
tout se décide de tout le temps pour les
socialistes nous sommes toujours en
renouvellement mais oui oui nous avons
besoin d'eux de nous re fondé de nour
constitué de nous refaire de cette
défaite de ce moment compliqué mais je
pense que le temps aujourd'hui n'est pas
à ça mais il va l'être très un effet
merci beaucoup béatrice vallée d'avre
est avec nous rappelle que vous êtes
membre du bureau politique des saucisses
de martinez conseillère fédérale là ils
fassent adverse merci de m'avoir à sion
[Musique]
des tacles